today we have Adam coats here for an
interview Adam you run the AI lab at
Baidu
in Silicon Valley could you just give us
a quick intro and explain what Baidu is
for people who don't know yeah so Baidu
is actually the largest search engine in
China so it turns out the internet
ecosystem in China is incredibly dynamic
environment and so Baidu I think sort of
turned out to be an early technology
leader and really established itself in
PC search but then also has sort of
remade itself in the mobile revolution
and increasingly today is becoming an AI
company recognizing the value of AI for
a whole bunch of different applications
not just search okay and so yet what do
you do exactly
so I'm the director of the Silicon
Valley AI lab which is one of four labs
within Baidu research
so especially is Baidu is becoming an AI
company the need for a team to sort of
be on the bleeding edge and understand
all of the current research be able to
do a lot of basic research ourselves but
also figure out how we can translate
that into business and product impact
for the company that's increasingly
critical so that's what Baidu research
is here for and the AI lab in particular
we kind of founded recognizing how
extreme this problem was about to get so
I think the deep learning research and
AI research right now is flying forward
so rapidly that the need for teams to be
able to both understand that research
but also quickly translate it into
something that businesses and products
can use is more critical than ever so we
founded the AI lab to try to close that
gap and help the company move faster and
so then how do you break up your time in
between like doing basic research for
around AI and actually implementing like
bringing it forward to a product there's
no hard and fast rule to this I think
one of the things that we try to to
repeat to ourselves every day is that
we're mission oriented so the mission of
the AI lab is is precisely to create AI
technologies that can have a significant
impact on at least 100 million people
we chose this to sort of keep bringing
ourselves back to to the sort of final
goal that we want all the research we do
to ultimately ends up in the hands of
users and so sometimes that means that
we spot something that that needs to
happen in the world to really change
technology for the better and to help I
do but no one knows how to solve it and
there's a basic research problem there
that someone has to tackle and so will
will sort of go back to our visionary
stance and think about the long term and
invest in research and then as we have
success there we shift back to to the
other foot and take responsibility for
carrying all of that to a real
application and making sure we don't
just solve the 90% that you might put in
say your research paper but we also
solve the last the last mile we get to
the 99.9 percent so maybe maybe the best
way to do this then is to just explain
like something that's started with
research here and how that's been
brought on to like a full on product
that exists so I'll give you an example
we we've spent a ton of time on speech
recognition so speech recognition you
years ago as one of these technologies
that always felt pretty good but not
good enough and so traditionally speech
recognition systems have been heavily
optimized for things like mobile search
so if you hold your phone up close to
your mouth
and you say a short area you made
non-human voice exactly the systems
could figure it out and they're getting
quite good I think you know the speech
engine that we've built it by do called
deep speech it's actually super human
for these short queries because you have
no context people can have thick accents
so that speech engine actually started
out as a basic research project we
looked at this problem we said gosh what
would happen if speech recognition were
human level for every product you ever
used so whether you're in your home or
in your car or you pick up your phone
whether you hold your phone up close or
hold it away if I'm in the kitchen and
my toddler is you know yelling at me can
I still use a speech interface
could it work as well as a human being
understands us and so then how do you do
that what is the basic research that
moved it forward to put it in a place
that it's useful so we have the
hypothesis that maybe the thing holding
back a lot of the progress in speech is
actually just scale maybe if we took
some of the same basic ideas we could
see in the research literature already
and scaled them way up put in a lot more
data invested a lot of time in solving
computational problems and built a much
larger neural network than anyone had
been building before for this problem we
could just get better performance and lo
and behold with with a lot of effort we
ended up with this pretty amazing speech
recognition model like I said in
Mandarin at least is actually super
human you can actually sit there and
listen to a voice query that someone is
trying out and you'll have native
speakers sitting around debating with
each other wondering what the heck the
person is saying Wow and then the speech
engine will give an answer and everybody
goes oh that's what it was because it's
just such a thick accent from perhaps
someone in rural China how much how much
data do you have to give it to train it
you know to train it on a new line
because I think on the site I saw it was
English and Mandarin yeah like if I
wanted German how much would I have to
give it so one of the big challenges for
these things is that they need a ton of
data so our English system uses like 10
to 20,000 hours of audio the Mandarin
systems are using even more for four-top
and products so this certainly means
that the technologies at a state where
to get that superhuman performance
you've got to really care about it so so
for Baidu voice search maps things like
that that our flagship products we can
put in the capital and the effort to do
that but it's also one of the exciting
things going forward in the basic
research that we think about is how do
we get around that how can we develop
machine learning systems that get you
human performance on every product and
do it with a lot less data so what I was
wondering then like did you see that
Lyrebird thing that was floating around
the event this week okay they claim that
they don't need all that much time all
that much data audio data to emulate
your voice or similar
whatever they call you guys have a
similar project going on right that's
right yeah we're working on Texas why
can they achieve that with less data I
think the the technical challenge behind
all of this is there's sort of two
things that we can do one is to try to
share data across many applications so
to take text-to-speech is one example if
I learn to mimic lots of different
voices and then you give me the 1000 and
first voice you hope that the first
thousand taught you virtually everything
you need to know about language and that
what's left is really some idiosyncratic
change that you could learn from very
little data so that's one possibility
the other side of it is that a lot of
these systems this is much more
important for things like speech
recognition that we were talking about
is we want to move from using supervised
learning where a human being has to give
you the correct answer in order for you
to train your neural network but move to
unsupervised learning where I could just
give you a lot of raw audio and have you
learn the mechanics of speech before I
ask you to learn a new language and
hopefully that can also bring down the
amount of data that we need and so then
on the technical side like could you
give us just a yeah somewhat of an
overview of how that actually works like
how how do you process a voice for
text-to-speech let's do both actually
because I'm super interested right so
closely let you start with yeah let's
start with speech recognition before we
go and train a speech system what we
have to do is collect a whole bunch of
audio clips so for example if we wanted
to build a new voice search engine I
would need to get lots of examples of
people speaking to me giving me little
voice queries and then I actually need
human annotators or I need some kind of
system that can give me ground truth
that can tell me for a given audio clip
what was the correct transcription and
so once you've done that you can ask a
deep learning algorithm to learn the
function that predicts the correct
text transcript from the audio clip so
this is this is called supervised
learning
it's an incredibly successful framework
we're really good with with this for
lots of different applications but the
big challenge there is those labels that
someone has to be able to sit there and
give you say ten thousand hours worth of
labels which can be really expensive so
how does it actually recognize what is a
software doing to recognize the
intonation of the word well
traditionally what you would have to do
is break these problems down into lots
of different stages so I as a speech
recognition expert would sit down and I
would think a lot about what are the
mechanics of this language so for for
Chinese you would have to think about
tonality and how to break up all the
different sounds into some intermediate
representation and then you would need
some sophisticated piece of software we
called a decoder that goes through and
tries to map that sequence of sounds to
possible words that it might represent
and so you have all these different
pieces and you'd have to engineer each
one often with its own expert knowledge
but deep speech and all of the new deep
learning systems we're seeing now try to
solve this in one fell swoop so the
really the answer to your question is
kind of the vacuous one which is that
once you give me the audio clips and the
characters that it needs to output a
deep learning algorithm can actually
just learn to predict those characters
directly and in the past it always
looked like there was some fundamental
problem that maybe we could never escape
this need for these hand engineered
representations but it turns out that
once you have enough data all of those
things go away and so where where did
your data come from like 10,000 hours of
audio we actually do a lot of clever
tricks in English where we don't have a
lot of a large number of English
language products so for example it
turns out that if you go onto say a
crowdsourcing service you can hire
people very cheaply to just read books
to you and
it it's not the same as the kinds of
audio that we hear in real applications
but it's enough to teach a speech system
all about you know liaisons between
words and you get some speaker variation
and you hear strange vocabulary where
English spelling is totally ridiculous
and in the past you would hand engineer
these things you'd say well I've never
heard that word before so I'm going to
bake the pronunciation into my speech
engine but now it's all data driven so
if I hear enough of these unusual words
you see these neural networks actually
learn to spell on their own even
considering all the weird exceptions of
English interesting and you have the
input right because I've heard of people
doing it with like a YouTube video but
then you need a caption as well with the
audio so it's twice as much if not more
work interesting and so then what about
the other way around how does that work
on the technical side right so that's
one of the really kind of cool parts of
deep learning right now is that a lot of
these insights about what works in one
domain keep transferring to other
domains so with text-to-speech you could
see a lot of the same practices so you
would see that a lot of systems were
hand engineered combinations of many
different modules and each module would
have its own set of machine learning
algorithms with its own little tricks
and so one of the things that our team
did recently with a piece of work that
we're calling deep voice was to just ask
what if I rewrote all of those modules
using deep learning for every single one
to not put them all together just yet
but even just ask can deep learning
solve all of these adequately to to get
a good speech system interrupt the
answer is yes that you can basically
abandon most of this specialized
knowledge in order to to build all of
the subsequent modules and in more
recent research that's in the deep
learning community is seeing that of
course everyone is now figuring out how
to make these things work end to end
they're all data driven and that's the
same story we saw for for deep speech so
we're really excited about that that's a
while and so do you have a team just
dedicated to parsing like research
coming out of universities and then
figuring
how to apply it are you testing
everything that comes out it's a bit of
a mix is definitely our role to not only
think about AI research but to think
about AI products and how to get these
things to impact I think there is
clearly so much a I research happening
that it's impossible to to look through
everything but one of the big challenges
right now is to not just digest
everything but to identify the things
that are truly important so what's like
a looks like a ninety million person
product that's a sure like element well
the speech recognition we chose because
we felt in aggregate it had that
potential so as we have the next wave of
AI products I think we're going to move
from these sort of bolted on AI features
to really immersive AI products so if
you look at how keyboards were designed
you know a few years ago for for your
phone you see that everybody just bolted
on a microphone and they hooked it up to
their speech API and then that was fine
for for that level of technology but as
the technology is getting better and
better we can now start putting speech
up front we can actually build a voice
first keyboard so it's actually
something we've been prototyping in the
AI lab we act you can actually download
this for your Android phone so it's
called puck type in case anybody wants
to try it yeah but is remarkable how
much it changes your habits I use it all
the time and I never thought I would do
that and so it emphasized to me why the
AI lab is here that we can sort of
discover these changes in user habits we
can understand how speech recognition
can impact people much more deeply than
it could when it was just bolted onto a
product and that sort of Spurs us on to
start looking at the full range of
speech problems that we have to solve to
get you away from this sort of close
talking voice search scenario and to one
where I can just talk to my phone or
talk to a device and have it always work
so as you'd like you know given this to
a bunch of users I assume and gotten
their feedback have you been surprised
with the IKE voice as in
I know lots of people talk about it some
people say like it doesn't really make
sense you know for example you see like
Apple transcribing voicemails now
are there certain use cases where you've
been surprised at how effective it is
and now there's where you're like I
don't know if this will ever play out
you know I think you know the really
obvious ones like texting seem to be the
most popular I think the feedback that
is maybe the most fun for me is for when
people with thick accents post a review
they say oh I have this like you know
crazy accent I grew up with and nothing
works for me but I try I tried this new
keyboard and it works amazingly well I
have a friend who has a thick Italian
accent and he complains all the time
that nothing works
and and all of this stuff now works for
four different accents because it's all
data-driven we don't have to think about
how we're going to serve all these
different users if they're represented
in the data sets and we get some
transcriptions we can actually serve
them in a way that really wasn't
possible when we were trying to do it
all by hand that's fantastic and have
you got it like through the whole system
in other words like if I want to give
myself you know an Italian American
accent what can I do that yet with Baidu
we can't do that yet with our TTS engine
but it is definitely on the way okay
cool so what else was on the way what
are you researching what products are
you working on what's coming to speech
and text-to-speech I think these are
part of a big effort to make this next
generation of AI products really fly
once text to speech and speech are your
primary interface to a new device they
have to be amazingly good and after work
for everybody and so I think there's
actually still quite a bit of room to
run on those topics not just making it
work for a narrow domain but making it
work for for really the full breadth of
what humans can do do you see a world
where you can run this stuff locally or
will they always be calling anything
yeah I think it's definitely going to
happen one kind of funny thing is that
if you look at folks who maybe have a
lot less technical knowledge and don't
really have the sort of instinct to
think through how a piece of technology
is working on the back end I think the
the response to a lot of AI
analogies now because they're reaching
this sort of uncanny valley is that we
often respond to them as though they're
sort of human and and that sets the bar
really high our expectations for for how
delightful a product should be is now
being set by our interactions with
people and one of the things we
discovered as we were translating deep
speech into a production system was that
latency is a huge part of that
experience that the difference between
50 or 100 milliseconds of latency and
200 milliseconds of latency is actually
quite perceptible and it really anything
we can do to bring that down actually
affects user experience quite a bit we
actually did a combination of research
production hacking working with product
teams thinking through how to make all
of that work and that's a big part of
this sort of translation process that
we're here for that's very cool and so
you know what happens on the technical
side to make it run faster so when we
first started like the basic research
for for deep speech like like all
research papers you know we choose the
model that gets the best benchmark score
which turns out to be horribly
impractical or we're putting on line and
and so after sort of the initial
research results team sat down with just
a set of what you might think of as
product requirements and started
thinking through the what kinds of
neural network models will allow us to
get the same performance but don't
require so much sort of future context
they don't have to listen to the entire
audio clip before they can give you a
really high accuracy response so kind of
doing that like you know the language
prediction stuff like the opening I guys
we're doing with the Amazon reviews like
predicting what's coming next maybe not
even predicting what's coming next but
one thing that humans do without
thinking about it is if if I
misunderstand a word that you said to me
and then a couple of words later I pick
up context that disambiguates it
I actually don't skip a beat I just
understand that as one long stream and
so one of the ways that our speech
systems would do this is that they would
listen to the entire audio clip first
process it all in one fell swoop and
then give you a final answer and that
works great for getting the highest
accuracy but it doesn't work so great
for a product where you need to give a
response online give people some
feedback that lets them know that you're
listening and so you need to alter the
neural network so that tries to give you
a really good answer using only what
it's heard so far but can then update it
very quickly as it gets more contacts so
I've noticed over the past few years
people have like gotten quite good at
structuring sentences so Syria
understands them hmm
you know they put like the noun in the
correct position so it like feeds back
to data correctly I found this when I
was traveling like I was using a Google
Translate and I after like one day
recognized that I couldn't give it a
sentence but if I gave it a noun I could
just show it to someone and like if I
just show like you know bread it will
translate it perfectly and give it do
you find that like we're going to have
to slightly adapt how we communicate
with machines or your goal is to
communicate like perfectly as we would I
really want it to be human level and I
don't see a serious barrier to getting
there at least for really high valued
applications I think there's a lot more
research to do but I I sincerely think
there's a chance that over the next few
years we're going to regard speech
recognition as a solved problem that's
very cool so what what are the really
hard things happening right now like
what are you not sure if it'll work
so I think we were talking earlier about
getting all this data so I problems
where we can just get gobs of labeled
data I think we've got a little bit more
room to run there but we can certainly
solve those kinds of applications but
there's a huge range of what humans are
able to do often without thinking that
current speech engines just don't handle
we can deal with crosstalk and a lot of
background noise if you talk to me from
the other side of a room even if there's
a lot of reverberation and things going
on it usually doesn't bother anybody
that much and yet current speech systems
often have a really hard time with this
but for the next generation of AI
products they're going to need to handle
all of this and so a lot of the research
that we're doing now is folk
just on trying to go after all of those
other things how do I handle people who
are talking over each other or handle
multiple speakers who are having a
conversation very casually how do i
transcribe things that have very long
structure to them like a lecture where
over the course of the lecture I might
realize I misunderstood something
or a little bit of jargon gets spelled
out for me and now I need to go and
transcribe it so this is one place where
our ability to innovate on products is
actually really useful we've just
launched recently a product vision
called swift scribe to help
transcriptionist be much more efficient
and that's targeted at understanding all
of these scenarios where the world wants
this long form transcription we have all
of these conversations that we're having
that are just sort of lost and we wish
we had written down but it's just too
expensive to transcribe all of it for
for every day application so do um so in
terms of emulating someone's voice do
you have any concerns for faking it
because I did you see the the face
simulation I forget the the researchers
name so I'll link to it but you know
what I'm talking about
so essentially you can like feed it both
video and audio and you can recreate you
know Adam talking do you have any
thoughts on like how we can prepare for
that world you know I think in some
sense this is a social question right I
I think culturally we're all going to
have to exercise a lot of critical
thinking we've always had this problem
in some sense that I can read an article
that has someone's name on it and
notwithstanding understanding writing
style I don't know for sure where that
article came from and so I think we have
habits for how to deal with that
scenario we we can be healthily
skeptical and I think we're going to
have to come up with ways to adapt that
to this sort of brave new world I think
those are big challenges coming up and I
do think about them but I also think a
lot about just all the positives that
that AI is going to have I you know I
don't talk about it too much like my
mother actually has muscular dystrophy
and so
things like speech and language
interfaces are just incredibly valuable
for for someone who cannot type on an
iPad because the keys are too far apart
and so these are just all these like
things that you don't really think about
that that these technologies are going
to address over the next few years and
on balance I know that we're going to
have a lot of big challenges of like how
do we use these how do we as users adapt
to all of the implications but I think
we've done really well with this in the
past and we're going to keep doing well
with it in the future so do you think
we're a I will create new jobs for
people or will we all be like Mechanical
Turk speeding ok I'm not sure I think
this is this is something where you know
the job turnover in the United States
every quarter is incredibly high it is
actually shocking that the fraction of
our workforce that quits one occupation
and moves to another one is really high
I think it is clearly getting faster
like we talked about this phenomenon
within the AI lab here where the deep
learning research is flying ahead so
quickly that we're often remaking
ourselves too to keep up with it and to
make sure that we can keep innovating I
think that might even be a little bit of
a lesson for for everyone that continual
learning is going to become more and
more important going forward yes so
speaking of like what are you teaching
yourself so the robots don't take your
job I don't think we're at risk of
robots taking our jobs right now I
actually it's kind of interesting we
thought a lot about like how does this
change careers one thing that has been
true in the past is that if you were to
create a new research lab one of the
first things you do is fill it with AI
experts where they live and breathe AI
technology all day long I think that's
really important I think for basic
research you need that kind of
specialization but because the field is
moving so quickly we also need a
different kind of person now
we also need people who are sort of
chameleons who are these highly flexible
is that can understand and even
contribute to a research project but can
also simultaneously shift to the other
foot and think about how does this
interact with GPU hardware and a
production system and how do I think
about a product team and user experience
because often product teams today can't
tell you what to change in your machine
learning algorithm to make the user
experience better it's very hard to
quantify where it's falling off the edge
and so you have to be able to think that
through to change the algorithms you
also have to be able to look at the
research community to think about what's
possible and what's coming and so
there's a sort of amazing full-stack
machine learning engineer that's
starting to show up are they coming from
like if I if I want to be that person
what do I do
like now Sam you know eighteen they seem
to be really hard to find right now
leave it so in the AI library we really
set ourselves to just creating them I
think this is sort of the way unicorns
are that we have to find the first few
examples and see how exciting that is
and then come up with a way for for
people to to learn and become that sort
of sort of professional actually one of
the cultural characteristics of our team
is that we look for people who are
really self-directed and hungry to learn
that things are going so quickly we just
can't guess what we're going to have to
do in six months and having that sort of
do-anything attitude saying well I'm
going to do research today and think
about research papers but Wow once we
get some traction and the results are
looking good we're going to take
responsibility for getting this all the
way to 100 million people that's a
towering request of anyone on our team
and the things that we find really help
everyone sort of connect to that and do
really well with that is really
self-directed and able to kind of deal
with ambiguity and also really willing
to learn a lot of stuff that isn't just
AI research but is also stepping way
outside of comfort zones and learning
about GPUs and high-performance
computing and learning about how a
product manager thing
okay so this has been super helpful if
if someone wanted to learn more about
what you guys are working on or even
just things that have been influential
to you like what would you recommend
they check out on the internet oh my
goodness so I have to think about this
for a second here I think the the stuff
that's actually been quite influential
for me is actually like startup books I
think especially with big companies it's
easy to think of ourselves in silos of
having a single job one idea from the
startup world that I think is really
amazingly powerful is this idea that a
huge fraction of what you're doing is
learning there's a tendency especially
amongst engineers which I count my I
count myself a member it's like we want
to build something and so one of the
disciplines I we all have to keep in
mind is that we also have to be really
clear eyed and think about what do we
not know right now and focus on learning
as quickly as we can to find the most
important part of AI research that's
happening and find the most important
pain point that people in the real world
are experiencing and then be really fast
at connecting those and I think a lot of
that influence on my thinking has come
from the startup world there you go
that's a great answer okay cool thanks
man thanks so much
you